[Music]
how the school worked when we
started we had practically nothing at
all even having the features it was
difficult because it's
pure and simple volunteering
the children don't pay to come and
learn one that it's  was difficult at
first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
children a man has a huge pot
very quickly because it's children
who had hardly set foot
in school I want  say none of them
have family worse for the screen
before we used
the ivory only children who already
correctly wrote their name
it's this prize best French
perform operations in mathematics
[Music]
very important  it's significant in
terms of progress
[Music]
la nomada maraboutique
nomades à magog
arthur adams [ __ ]
[Music]